nein der Energiestrategie ist
gescheitert ich meine die deutsche
Energiepolitik ist eigentlich eine
Katastrophe für die Wirtschaft da fehlt
der Strom das fehlt Energie es ist eine
Katastrophe auch für die Bürger die
Energiepreis explodieren es ist aber
noch eine Katastrophe für die
Versorgungssicherheit weil eben auch
nicht mehr gewährleistet ist es ist
einfach schlichtweg dumm dass meine ein
Energiestrategie fährt dass man nur auf
Elektrifizierung setzt und vieles anders
aus der Kraft lässt aus Sicht lässt das
kann eigentlich nicht funktionieren man
steigt das eine klimafreundlichen
Kernenergie aus und gleichzeitig sagt
man eben man macht Klimapolitik das geht
alles hinten und vorne nicht auf nur
erneuerbare da fehlen schlichte
Ressourcen in diesem Land und
Deutschland ist ein Wirtschaftsmotor
Deutschland ist ein Exportnation dem
sagen wir alles tschüss das funktioniert
dann so nicht mehr und ja es ist keine
Überzeugung der Strategie diese
Energiewende es braucht jetzt die Wände
von der Wende das ist eigentlich dumm
was Deutschland gemacht hat aber nachdem
man das dass die Schweiz das
nachvollzogen hat auch wir haben eine
Energiewende gemacht und die
funktioniert auch bei uns nicht also es
ist wirklich nicht nur ein Beispiel und
man kann das Zeigen das zieht sich
eigentlich durch ist Energiewende ist
auf eine Ideologie basierend und nicht
auf Physik und Ökonomie und das müsste
eigentlich die Tatsachen müssen
entscheiden und nicht Ideologien von
links grüner Seite wir lassen mal die
Politik direkt antworten würde ich sagen
Herr Strasser sie haben das gehört hier
wird befürchtet deutsche Konzerne
wandern ab wann er dahin wo sie es
besser bezahlen können wie nehmen sie
das auf also in den letzten Jahren hat
die Vorgänger Regierung oder Vorgänger
Regierungen durchaus Fehler gemacht man
kann ja jetzt nicht sagen dass alles nur
an erneuerbaren liegt sonst hätten wir
das Problem ja nicht wir haben jetzt
momentan ein akutes gasproblem wir
organisieren als Bundesregierung
Maßnahmen wie wir das substituieren also
beispielsweise mit längeren Laufzeiten
für deutsche kann Kraftwerke wir hätten
uns als Freie Demokraten da noch
deutlich mehr vorstellen können wir
blicken auch
auch gespannt auf das Frühjahr ich
glaube wir müssen uns das da auch noch
mal anschauen ob das sozusagen ausreicht
oder ob mir über eine weitere
Verlängerung sprechen müssen und wenn
man die Energiewende der letzten Jahre
anschaut dann war es ja auch so dass
unter anderem in Bayern Stromtrassen
blockiert und verhindert worden sind von
der CSU also die Weiterleitung des
Stroms aus dem Norden in den Süden und
die Grünen eine Energiepolitik gemacht
haben die eben nicht technologieoffen
ist die nicht auf synthetische
Kraftstoffe gesetzt hat die nicht auf
Wasserstoff gesetzt hat wenn man einen
Strich drunter zieht auch für die als
Perspektive für die kommenden Jahre ist
klar dass Deutschland nie ein
energieautarkes Land war auch in der
Vergangenheit mit rein fossilen
Kraftstoffen nicht deswegen haben wir
ein ureigenes Interesse dass wir
beispielsweise investieren in die
Produktion von grünem Wasserstoff in
Nordafrika beispielsweise in Chile das
eben beides zusammen geht bezahlbare
Energieversorgung und
könnte man aber fast denken sie sind
nicht mit ihrer Partei in der Regierung
die da ja auch einiges verantwortlich
nein das ist das ist auch die Position
der Freien Demokraten ich will noch mal
sagen wir regieren jetzt seit einem Jahr
und wir haben den einen milliar deutlich
mehr geschafft als die Union in 16
Jahren die sich hier in Deutschland
Regierungspolitik betreibt noch gehen
wir noch mal rein ins Thema
planungsbeschleunigung unser Haus des
Bundesjustizministerium hat jetzt ganz
konkret ein Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt zur
Beschleunigung von Gerichtsverfahren
dass eben weniger auch Einsprüche
eingelegt werden können sondern das
schneller baurech da ist und das gilt
für uns nicht nur für erneuerbare
Energien sondern wir haben in dieser
Koalition durchgesetzt also auch für den
Straßenbau gilt auch das ist ein Punkt
wo Deutschland zeigen kann was in uns
steckt
Atomkraftwerke einmal möchte ich ja noch
einhaken laufen die weiter ist nur bis
April setzen sie sich weiter dafür
einfach wie dass ihre Partei das ist ja
kein Geheimnisse haben wir auch gesagt
auch nach der Entscheid das
Bundeskanzlers dass wir das unserem
Frühjahr noch mal auf der Agenda nehmen
wollen und die Lage anschauen wollen es
ist schon erst so guter Schritt dass wir
die Verlängerung durchgesetzt haben in
der Koalition
da muss man planen also wann genau
sprechen wir darüber dann wenn langsam
alles schon runter fährt
wir beobachten die Lage natürlich auch
jetzt schon so sozusagen das ist ja
nicht so dass wir bis bis April die
Augen verschließen vor der Lage die in
Deutschland ist wir haben viel geschafft
die Gasspeicher sind jetzt voll wer
hätte uns das noch vor wenigen Monaten
zugetraut dass wir jetzt in aller Lage
sind wo 100 % an Gas eingespeichert ist
wir haben weitere Energiequellen
erschlossen wir werden auch darüber
diskutieren müssen über das Thema
Schiefer Gasförderung in Deutschland
also die eigenen Gasquellen auch zu
erschließen das heißt das ist ein
Maßnahmen Mix die kann Energie allein
wird uns nicht aus dieser Situation
helfen sondern sie ist ein wichtiger
Teil davon sie ist aber nicht die
alleinige Lösung
Unternehmen gehen die nicht vorher nein
das war ich natürlich nicht meines man
merkt natürlich dass sie eingebunden
sind da in die Regierung deshalb will
ich beißhemmungen haben und auch die
Liberalen sonntagspredigen sind
natürlich nicht überzeugend meine sie
müssen doch ganz klar dass liberaler
Politiker hinstehen und sagen
technologieverbote das ist ganz falsch
sie haben es angesprochen zum Teil
Verbrennungsmotoren Verbot das ist
völlig konterproduktiv da werden durch
neue Technologien abgeschnitten e-fuß
Wasserstoff und so weiter und muss auch
bedenken weltweit sind über 1,3
Milliarden Verbrennungsmotoren im
Betrieb und wenn ihr diese Technologie
einfach abschneiden sie können nicht
einfach von heute auf morgen Afrika z.B
nur noch Tesla herumfahren lassen als
wenn Sie eine ganze Welt denken ist eine
sehr egoistische Politik nur auf
Elektrifizierung zu setzen und ich meine
von einem liberalen warte die ich teile
das ist völlig klar das sind
technologieverbote Fehler Platz es
braucht Kernkraftwerk es gibt neueste
Generationen sehr gut gute und ich
verstehe das überhaupt nichts rein
Ideologie und die Schaden am Schluss der
Wirtschaft die schadet den Bürgern in
diesem Land und das kann eigentlich sein
und dieses Versteckspiel hinter
Regierung ich weiß sie sitzen mit dem
grünen da im selben Boot aber das da
müsste schon klare Kante geben als
liberale Politik in Deutschland lesen
weil 80% der Deutschen kann Energie
nicht wollen dann ist diese Frage
eigentlich schon vor zehn Jahren
entschieden worden und selbst das hat
auch nichts mit Regierung oder
Opposition zu tun schauen sich mal die
Union in Deutschland an es fordert
keiner in Deutschland einen kompletten
Wiedereinstieg wir brauchen
Kohlekraftwerke wieder auf sie machen
gute Besserung
oder Steinkohle würde ich mal sagen
paar mal die stirngeruntern den Kopf
geschüttelt und paar Mal glaube ich zu
erkennen dass ein Augenwinkeln
vorsichtig genickt nehmen
euch gerne also den mit die Stirn
gerunzelt habe ich vor allem am Anfang
bei der Analyse ich glaube da geht viel
durcheinander weil Energie ist jetzt
gerade teuer nicht weil irgendwie links
grüne Ideologie sondern weil
konservative Sturheit und sparwhut weil
wir nicht investiert haben weil wir bei
Wind und Solar noch nicht weit genug
sind weil wir die Anfänge der deutschen
Solarindustrie verloren haben die sind
jetzt in China weil der Ausbau
zurückgegangen ist ja und während wir
heute dabei weiter hätten wir mehr Wind
und Solar Energie müssten wir gar nicht
so viel Gas verstromen aber der Strom
günstiger und werden mehr Gas über um zu
speichern um über den Winter zu kommen
von daher konservative
Utopie in dieser erzählen das hat nichts
mit dem Wirtschaft und Physikalität zu
tun sie kennen vielleicht ein Begriff
dunkelflasche was passiert wenn sie
keinen Solarstrom haben wenn es keinen
Winter ist wenn alles zusammen kommt das
kann nicht funktionieren diese
Erneuerbaren es gibt übrigens heute ist
der Schweiz neue Studie rausgekommen von
einem liberalen Sync zeigt sie haben
ausgerechnet es kann gar nicht
funktionieren nur mit Erneuerbaren
können haben sie gar nicht genug
Ressourcen das kann nicht funktionieren
wenn Sie das jetzt wieder erzählen hätte
man doch nur für das gemacht es ist ein
kleiner Anteil überhaupt eine neue Bahn
bis jetzt da und das kann man nicht
einfach hin zwingen und wir brauchen
jetzt Strom wir brauchen zukunftstrom
und die brauchen viel mehr Strom das
wäre auch immer außer Acht gelassen wenn
sie voll auf Elektrifizierung setzen
wenn sie sagen Verbrennungsmotoren Weg
die Mobilität muss elektrifiziert wenn
die Heizung alles muss elektrifiziert
werden dann haben sie z.B Schweiz und
ganz starke Zuwanderung das frisst alles
zusätzlich Strom und diesen Strom müssen
sie können es nicht einfach ersetzen mit
der neue waren Energie in dieser
Richtung
ja also wenn man sich jetzt heute
anguckt wo wir Strom herbekommen da ist
ja Atom auch im Vergleich zu den
erneuerbaren kleinen deswegen noch mal
die Frage zurück ist es denn würden Sie
sagen hätten wir wenn wir bei Wind und
war schon weiter hätten wir heute
weniger gasprobleme werde Strompreis
günstiger würden sie dazu Stimmen ich
glaube nicht dass es günstig ist weil
die sich
glauben machen Sie mit dem großen
Illusionen Utopien immer wieder auf die
Physik und auf die ökonomischen
Tatsachen der Schweiz haben wir ein
Drittel keine Energie und wenn man das
abstellt da fehlt ein Drittel und es
wird eben viel mehr Strom wie gesagt in
Zukunft noch gebraucht also die Lücke
wird noch viel größer und das können sie
nicht einfach so setzen mit ein paar
windräschen und mit ein paar fotomotage
Anlagen auf einem Dach das reicht
einfach nicht Frau jung will diese
Diskussion gerade auf Sie also sie
können ohne Zweifel den Herren irgendwas
für Blutdruck wenn Sie hier oben aber
wir haben uns ganz real auch ihre
Probleme ihre Herausforderungen und auch
ihre Befürchtungen für die Zukunft
geschildert wie wird das dass sie wird
tauchen hier sehr tief einige Materie
jeder tauscht seine Argumente aus sagen
Sie uns auch einmal als BürgerInnen als
Apothekerin wie wird diese das also für
mich ist die Wind und Solarenergie nicht
dass man plus ultra also die ganze
Technologie hinkt einfach auch hinterher
es wären immer irgendwelche
Entscheidungen ganz oben getroffen das
kennen wir aber auch aus dem
Gesundheitswesen und es wird die Sache
nicht bis zum Ende gedacht weil
sicherlich wollen wir alle das Klima
retten und sind dafür dass die Welt
schöner und sauberer da steht aber das
schaffe ich doch nicht indem ich
Windparks ohne Ende
aufstelle die Bäume alle abrasiere
fahren Sie durch die Landschaft da
denken Sie sie wären auf dem Mond wenn
Sie die ganzen Windräder drehen möchte
ich so dass meine Umwelt aussieht für
meine Kinder nein ich möchte die Natur
haben und die Natur schaffen wir nicht
für unsere Kinder indem wir Windräder
und Solarplatten ohne Ende aufstellen
also das können wir gar nicht wir
müssten so viel platt machen im Land um
allein diese Energie hier anzuschaffen
das ist für Deutschland ist es einfach
fast in diskutabel für mich glauben Sie
sie holen Frau jünger ist WählerInnen ab
den Ausstieg wollen ne die 80% war
glaube ich nicht so eine also die 80
Prozent der Deutschen
zumindest nach Fukushima akut aber jetzt
auch wenn Sie die Umfragen jetzt
angucken wenn Sie diese Fragen möchten
wenn Sie die Umfragen jetzt auch gefragt
aufgrund der der Krise anschauen ne sind
die Leute für einen Wiedereinstieg in
die Kernkraft dann haben sie in
Deutschland einfach keine Mehrheit also
ich bin da 10 % wollen aussteigen ganz
aktuelle Umfrage ist von yogave also
ist das so aber es bringt ja nichts also
ich ich mache den Punkt gar nicht bei
der Sicherheit von von AKWs ne also da
ist Fukushima für mich nicht der Maßstab
die Frage ist natürlich was machen Sie
mit dem Atommüll
also wer hat denn das Endlager denn dann
in einer eigenen Nachbarschaft ne das
ist die gleiche Diskussion wie mit mit
der Photovoltaik was mir wichtig ist als
Punkt deswegen habe ich das noch vorhin
noch mal so unterstrichen Deutschland
wird nie ein energieautarkes Land werden
das war es auch nie also die Illusion
jetzt nur mit Photovoltaik oder mit
Windkraft sozusagen wir bauen jetzt
einfach so viel Windräder bis es reicht
das ist natürlich eine Illusion und das
natürlich naiv und deswegen brauchen wir
unter anderem das Thema Wasserstoff
deswegen brauchen wir unter anderem das
Thema e-fues beispielsweise für den
Schwerlastverkehr für Flugzeuge die
Frage kann ich natürlich nicht mit
Elektromobilität beantworten da spricht
die Physik schon Begegnung und so ein
Flugzeug überhaupt in die Luft
physikalisch zu bekommen deswegen ist
schon wichtig dass wir jetzt auch in der
weiteren Gestaltung der Energiewende
drauf achten dass sie in der Tat äh
technologieoffen ist und dafür haben wir
in der Regierung in dem Jahr indem wir
jetzt Verantwortung haben durchaus mit
konkreten Maßnahmen dafür ges aus dem
Südwesten Deutschlands Baden-Württemberg
Daimler die Autoindustrie wir haben die
derzeit voraussichtlich wir haben zu
Hause sogar ein eigenes
Familienunternehmen im Automotive
Bereich umso besser schildern Sie uns
und ich kann Ihnen sagen Energiepreise
ist ein Thema ein wichtiges Thema für
unsere Unternehmen aber nicht das
Entscheidende wir haben gar nicht die
Arbeitskräfte in unseren Unternehmen
damit wir dir Aufträge abarbeiten können
die da sind wir haben das Problem von
gestörten Lieferketten dass wir die
Produkte die wir brauchen um unser
Portfolio anzubieten gar nicht
herstellen können also wenn man wenn man
zu Recht
Befürchtungen hat wie geht's mit unseren
Industrie unsere Mittelstand weiter dann
ist es eben nicht nur die Frage von
Energiepolitik sondern ist auch die
Frage von Einwanderung nicht nur
Fachkräfte Einwanderung sondern
Arbeitskräfte Einwanderung in den
Arbeitsmarkt nicht in die Sozialsystem
um diese Herausforderung zu bewältigen
und deswegen ist natürlich wirklich der
ganze Automotive Bereich in einem großen
Umstellungsprozess das viele Pleite
Zulieferer ja also die Frage ist ich
kenne baden-württembergische Unternehmen
also bin ich aufgewachsen immer als
Tüftler und Erfinder mein Vater ist so
ein klassischer Tüftler und Erfinder hat
mehrere Patente und natürlich ist es
eine Riesenherausforderung für uns als
Familienunternehmen unsere
Produktpalette anzupassen und Zuschauen
wo ist unser neuer Markt aber auch das
ist natürlich Teil von von
Marktwirtschaft sich immer wieder auch
neu zu erfinden als Unternehmen und die
die entscheidende Frage ist wie
verhindern wir strukturbrüche wie
gestalten wir diesen Strukturwandel und
da ist technologieoffenheit ein ein
entscheidender Aspekt beim Deutschen
Bundestag sitzen in übergroßen Mehrzahl
eben keine Ingenieurinnen und Ingenieure
sondern andere Berufsgruppen ich bin
Rechtsanwalt und deswegen ist es mir
auch wichtig in den Entscheidungen immer
darauf zu achten was sagt uns
beispielsweise automobilkonzepte